uh jared padalecki was texting me this
morning what an [ __ ] he said he said
uh see if he's willing to tell you about
the fart on the plane story
[Laughter]
okay
uh yeah sure let's do it let's let's do
my fart story what is it so um i i don't
know how long your your podcast can run
but this is a long is it what can we
nope it has to be incredibly long
so
um all right i i was uh i was flying um
from los angeles to boston on jetblue
and stopped off before the flight to
have dinner with uh my wife's mother and
my wife and i were vegetarians at the
time and she took us to p.f chang's
china bistro and we had no money at this
point and so we gorged
on every vegetarian entree they had at
pf chang's there's a lot of roasted
garlic and everything it seemed like and
that's something that doesn't
necessarily agree with my system
we got on the flight and i was it was a
packed flight and i was sitting in a
middle seat
and about half hour into the flight i
felt like the pressure building up oh my
god i've gotta let i've gotta i've gotta
fart but i didn't wanna like excuse me
sorry get up get up and go to the
bathroom i was just gonna let it so i
decided what i would do is just let it
out a little bit at a time
so that it would dissipate and not be a
big deal and you know on the plane when
you fart it's like no one can hear it
nobody can hear because there's the
sound of the jet engine it's going to be
fine
so anyway i i
endeavored to let it out a little bit at
once but unfortunately when i don't
pressure change or something it all came
out at once and
just the fart
just just the fart came out and uh
and there was a guy sitting behind me
um who fainted
from your fart yeah and his uh his
girlfriend called the flight attendants
over and said
uh mike you know he's pat they came they
administered oxygen they resuscitated
him and she said somebody
somebody has gas and the flight
attendant said no no ma'am that's not
possible uh all of the all of the fuel
is stored on the wings there's nothing
none of the none of you the fuel could
come into the fuselage at all it's not
possible and so they all let it go i i
fell asleep i i woke up uh it was about
an hour later and i had to fart again
and i thought i'll just just a little
bit at a time again i farted again the
guy faints again they administer oxygen
and again his girlfriend says somebody
has gas
and the flight attendant again ma'am
that's not possible it's all you're
hearing all this 100 i'm hearing it all
i'm like slinking down into the seat i'm
absolutely mortified and the woman
sitting next to them in that in the row
said so they say no ma'am it's not
possible for there to be a gas leak and
the woman says no ah it's not a gas leak
somebody has to go to the bathroom
and so we land the plane
and everyone has to sit in their seats
while paramedics come and get this guy
off the plane shoot your pants as he's
saying as he's saying it's never
happened to me before i i don't know
it's just something smells so bad
oh my god
anyway that is superb so i don't know
what your sponsorship relationship is i
love
china
but if pf
isn't paying you they should be all
right that was an unbelievable story
because you know you know how much i
love farts ryan